hey guys Pete here today we're gonna
talk about Audrey Horne and we're gonna
talk about Audrey based on what we know
from the final dossier so do have to
give a spoiler warning here I'm going to
explain what it says and I still suggest
that you go and read the book first
before you watch this video so it's a
three hour read if you get the audible
version it takes about three hours to
listen to it there's a link in the
description here where you can go get it
I think the Kindle version is probably
only $9.99 so before you watch this
video and spoil it just consider reading
it it's a fun book it gives a lot of
answers and I think that everyone should
do that so that's my two bits or
whatever so now that that's out of the
way what we learned about Audrey is
inconclusive in some ways but we did
find out a lot there's only a couple
paragraphs there but in those paragraphs
we found out that she recovered from the
coma she had no memory of what happened
but she left the hospital and she seemed
to be on the road to a complete recovery
two different things happen in that
period of time one her father Ben went
ahead and sold the family's ghostwood
property and two she found out she was
pregnant now her father selling the
ghostwood estate land was basically an
unforgivable act she left the house she
refused any financial help from him
whenever she found out she was pregnant
and because of what happened with Donna
and the hayward family Ben and Sylvia
Horan also got a divorce and she moved
out so Sylvia was involved as a
grandmother with Richard on some levels
which we saw in the return but basically
Audrey set out to raise him on her own
she got a small apartment it says you
didn't take any money from Ben she
eventually went to Community College
studied business and things like that
and opened a hair salon which she ran up
until a few years before the events of
the return around Richard horns 10th
birthday she married Charlie he's not
mentioned by name in the in the book but
it's clearly the same guy or at least
the same idea and you know people said
basically
that it was a marriage about money not
about love according to what Tammy
Preston found out when she was
investigating for the dossiers Audrey
never mentioned who the father was she
never seemed interested in it she never
got a paternity test but the one thing
that Tammy notes is that she did keep a
photo of agent Cooper hanging in her
office after her marriage to the
accountant there were plenty of rumors
of heavy drinking infidelity all on
Audrey's part they eventually went to a
marriage counselor and she saw a
psychiatrist now there isn't really much
in the way of details about young
richard at all most of what we know
about him comes directly from season
three she did never let Ben meet Richard
though Richard never was a part like Ben
was never a part of Richard's life and
that's all pretty straightforward at
some point she shut down the hair salon
and she and the book says that no one
saw her after that she either started to
live in a agoraphobic lifestyle or there
were hints that she may have been
institutionalized so that's the official
story as far as what agent Tammy could
dig up whenever she was looking into her
past what about the returned then it's
still a little bit of a gray area
because well for one thing we know the
coma theory was wrong she's not in a
coma she did actually come out of the
coma I tend to think that since Tammy
mentioned that she might have been
institutionalized that she is currently
but that doesn't mean that she was right
away charlie is her real husband like I
said and it seems to me that all this
other stuff that was going on the most
likely explanation is that there was
some kind of psychosis
now the Charlie stuff that we saw in the
return was that in her mind while she
was institutionalized or is that you
know she's remembering being married
being stuck in the house before she got
in the hospital I mean we really can't
tell that for sure but we can deduce
that the evil cooperate theory is pretty
much on it was real it happened if he
was if agent Cooper was the father then
that's really the only way that could
have went down
and considering Richard in the way his
disposition was it makes a lot of sense
I think the biggest question for me
after having that information is why
include Audrey in the story and the way
that they did as we saw it in season
three I've read some pretty interesting
theories out there and I still tend to
lean towards the simplest explanation
evil cooper doppel coupe you know
whatever whatever you want to call him
he was evil
so her carrying that baby to term
obviously had negative effects on her I
think there is a blurring of lines and
then we talked about a lot of those
theories in the other Audrey video I
made and you know it seemed like there
was definitely a large influence on her
life I tend to come away from after the
final dossier thinking that that
influence was carrying the child and
Richard probably being a very difficult
child as a result of being born of the
law I mean that's I don't know how else
to describe that in a coherent way
there's other theories that are more
complicated but I just don't think that
it's really from a storytelling
perspective I don't think that it's much
else of we had all these high
expectations of Audrey coming back she
was the one of the charismatic character
she was in a cast of a lot of
good-looking people she was one of the
hottest and you know she was a big part
of the original run so I feel like it to
me they know the part I take away is you
know here's this girl she was beautiful
she had a upper-class upbringing
although we saw very clearly in the
first season into the second that she
had daddy issues and that she never got
you know she was always doing these
little things to try to get Ben's
attention and things just didn't work
out for her by chance something very
traumatic happened she had a child that
was conceived while she was in a coma
through the process of a large spirit
raping her I mean the only other thing I
mean they she found out that she was
pregnant two months after she had
recovered so there's really not much way
that you could twist that in a different
correction I mean people always like to
bring up JJ wheeler because of what
happened at the end of season 2 but I
mean there's no mention of any of that
in any of the material beyond season 2
so I just don't see any other real
conclusion other than that's what
happened and what we saw in the return I
think is either her she is
institutionalized and she's delusional
so she has these strange memories of the
hard time that she had before she got
put in the hospital with Charlie the
fact that they coincide with some of the
stuff we heard at the Roadhouse and
other things we could definitely go down
some rabbit holes there but I don't I
don't see anything clear other than she
was affected by the large spirits I
don't think we need alternate timelines
I don't agree needed really like any
kind of real complicated sci-fi stuff
here she was a good person with a bright
future and something bad happened to her
and for what we can guess she's probably
locked away in a mental institution at
this point her son turned out to be a
real piece of work
terrorized his grandmother terrorized
his mother probably in the same way that
we didn't see and then he was sent to
his demise by his own father
Yubel coop so that's where I land after
reading the whole thing I'd like to hear
what you guys think please let me know
in the comments make sure you like this
video if you enjoy it please check out
my patreon and think about joining us
over there the season one rewatch is
gonna be picking up I have worked on the
one and I will do that I'm really
obsessed with the final dossier right
now to be honest and I was trying to
figure out how to do a big video so
instead I'm just doing this one and then
I'll do them character by character or
situation by situation because there's
too much to try to throw in one long
video I think and and I really don't
want to give people an incentive to just
get the book spoiled and then not buy it
and read it for themselves I just think
that's the wrong direction but I'm sure
those videos are out there already where
everyone did that but that's just not
the way I do business
so anyways subscribe to my channel if
you haven't already make sure you hit
the bell so you have your notifications
on that's it for now thanks for watching
guys I'll talk
to you soon